[Musik]
herzlich willkommen zum sport rapport
dem sport podcast des österreichischen
bundesheers ich bin selbst herr der
sportler mein name ist andreas on air
und wir wollen euch hier die tollen
persönlichkeiten und spannenden
geschichten hinter den vielen herres
sportlerinnen und sportlern des
österreichischen bundesheers näher
bringen mein heutiger gast ist ein ganz
besonderer und ich freue mich wirklich
dass es zu uns zum sport trat geschafft
hat nämlich ferdinand zvonimir
habsburg-lothringen lieber ferdinand
herzlich willkommen beim sport rapport
erschien vielen dank wir haben uns
kennengelernt weil du deinen
grundausbildung zum teil auch beim herr
sportzentrum dieses jahr gemacht hast
wir haben noch vor der pandemie noch vor
dem ganzen chaos viele stunden gemeinsam
beim training oder auch beim mittag
abendessen und frühstückstisch verbracht
und was mir viele spannende geschichten
erzählt wir werden heute ein bisschen in
dieser geschichten hinein schleifen aber
du bist motorsportler das heißt
rennfahrer und nach dem grundwehrdienst
absolviert hast ist bei dir ja großartig
weitergegangen man könnte fast schon
sagen dass der grundwehrdienst war eine
initialzündung für deine karriere du
bist in der dtm und vers dort für rudi
waren die letzten monate für dich als
ein sportler ja wahnsinnig aufregend ich
meine jetzt hat die saison wirklich
begonnen
die komisch der saison ich glaube für
fast jeden sportler auf der welt weil
eigentlich ist das ja bei ihm das
eigentlich im april mai und 1
zu dieser zeit und wie wir bewusst sind
konnte es erst juli august beginnen und
geht jetzt in den november hinein
und ja es war viel zeit zum zum
reflektieren eine gute zeit für meinen
grundwehrdienst eben weil ich nicht
immer meine grundsätzlich machen wollte
aber es war immer schwierig den
perfekten zeitfenster zu finden dafür
und das heer sportzentrum hat mir genau
das gegeben eigentlich du hast auch
schon in der dtm jetzt seine ersten
erfolge aufgezeigt bist schon am podium
gestanden hast auch schon eine pole
position gehabt
welche erfahrungen hast du da für dich
so aus diesen ersten großen erfolgen im
rennsport mitnehmen können ja es war
ich meine ein bisschen ein bild zu bauen
das ist sehr hart begonnen eigentlich
mit vielen technischen problemen die wir
hatten
mit dem auto irgendwie motorsport ist
nicht der normalste sport egal wie viel
talent ohs das auto muss auch gut
funktionieren
und manchmal hat man probleme es gibt
eine millionen teil auf diesem auto die
alle perfekt harmonieren müssen um eine
performance zu liefern und die ist nicht
gekommen und es war immer eine oder das
andere problem am wochenende und dtm hat
so ein hohes niveau das man eigentlich
ein perfektes wochenende hat um nur die
möglichkeit haben am podium zu sein und
dann noch dazu muss man perfekt gefahren
haben und kleinigkeiten sind ein
bisschen im weg gestanden das kommt vor
und das hat mir eigentlich ziemlich viel
biss gegeben weil ich gewusst habe dass
es da ist und über die letzten wochen
ist das alles zusammengekommen das team
und ich und auch ich sage jetzt ein
neuer hersteller für mich audi wir haben
einfach viel geld zusammengekommen und
dieses podium hatte und jetzt zusammen
mit hoffentlich für lange zeit und damit
hast du auch gezeigt dass du auf jeden
fall ein podiums fahrer bist und dass
man mit ihr rechnen kann mit guten
siegen und erfolgen da war schon
angesprochen dass eine komische sohn war
du hast in dem sinne die perfekte zeit
gefunden und eine grundausbildung zu
machen
jetzt würden andere herres sportler und
sportlerinnen in der grundausbildung
natürlich die die grundausbildung machen
und dann die zeit auch zum trainieren
nutzen können
aber wie war das bei dir wir haben
natürlich beim esport keinen ring wo du
deine zu machen kannst wie kann man sich
sein training eines rennsportler
vorstellen ja ich meine motorsport ist
eine sache wo man gute ausdauer haben
muss es eine sm eine basis man muss
wahnsinnig viel konzentrationsfähigkeit
haben man muss die
koordinationsfähigkeit haben und auch
eine basis kraft im raum für im rücken
und die kraft ist hauptsächlich dafür da
für die g kräfte und großteils für
schutz falls man ein unfall hat damit
man nicht verletzt ist ich habe vor
mehreren jahren einen größeren unfall
capo ich mit dem rücken gebrochen habe
und das war hauptsächlich daran gelegen
ok viele kräfte aber auch ich glaube
dass man eine regeneration schneller
gewesen wäre weil ich stärker gewesen
und
ich bereits längere zeit dem grund
verdient hat viel trainieren können
also war nicht konnte und habe viel
kraft kann man verwenden können dort und
habe gleich beim ersten rennen einen
relativ angenehmen unfall gehabt wo wir
ein technisches problem hatten am auto
wo das gas hängen geblieben ist in einer
schnelleren kurven und bin mit absolut
null verletzungen außer vielleicht einem
roten herz puls ausgestiegen und ich
würde das runter tun so eine eine gute
vorbereitungsphase gutes training und 1
1 starken rom von rücken und das ist die
hauptsache auf die man sich
konzentrieren muss du warst ja schon
seit letztem jahr in der dtm also in der
deutschen tourenwagen-meisterschaft
fairsten martin was dort letzte
platzierte also auf platz 18 hast du die
saison abgeschlossen danach seinen
grundwehrdienst und jetzt geht es gleich
los und du gewinnst du auch schon
podiumsplätze war das vielleicht auch so
ein bisschen ein lehrjahr für dich
letztes jahr
na ja riesig ich meine auch erst martin
hat leider nicht das beste produkt
gehabt und wir waren die letzten vier
fahrern in der meisterschaft dichte
unerfahrenste hintendran ein
unregelmäßig jahr für jeden sportler
wenn man das erleben muss aber ich würde
sagen dass mein glaube stark geblieben
ist weil ich zu ende der saison meine
teamkollegen immer geschlagen habe ich
hab da auf eine bessere saison gehofft
das ist natürlich komplett in die luft
gejagt worden durch corona und so weiter
aber ich würde sagen dass das bundesheer
mir genug hoffnung gegeben hat das was
auch immer kommt wird etwas gutes sein
du hast doch schon vorher die 24 stunden
rennen angesprochen wo ist der
unterschied zwischen einem normalen
rennen und einem 24 stunden rennen außer
natürlich die dauer aber von der art und
weise wie du als rennfahrer dieses
rennen absolvieren musste musst du dich
anders vorbereiten muss daran dass
hineingehen ich meine das war jetzt ein
einlass mit call up eigentlich dass wir
jetzt nicht geplant das rennen zu fahren
das war am dienstag vor dem rennen habe
ich den anruf bekommen in einem auto zu
fahren dass ich noch nie gefahren bin
und in einem der härtesten und größten
für unsere truppen auf der welt zu
fahren
das ist eine sache auf die man sich
normalerweise gut vorbereiten will
mehrere wochen lagen deshalb dieses
looks da bin ich bekomme und ich würde
ich habe den anruf bekommen
in einer regenerationszeit
eigentlich nach zwei dtm rennen
miteinander und war eigentlich immer zu
hause dann hab ich darauf gekommen packt
seine sachen und fuhr sofort nach zwar
auf ich hab natürlich nicht nein gesagt
und bin hoch gefahren und bin
eingestiegen mit sehr wenig vorbereitung
aber mit einem guten gefühl eigentlich
ich bin als 140 schon davor gefahren und
habe momentan sehr viel selbstvertrauen
gehabt durch meinen erfolgreichen dtm
rennen und das schwierige private
stunden rennen ist einen fokus hoch zu
halten viel von sich zu erwarten und mit
wenig schlaf und ich würde sagen das hat
mir großteils das bundesheer viel
selbstvertrauen gegeben weil in der
grundausbildung lernt man oft mit wenig
schlaf und mit wenig erholung sehr viel
aus sich selbst heraus holen zu können
und es zeigt dir eine große lassen als
sportler mich mehr zu pushen als wie ich
sie damals davor tun konnte oder machen
wollte das haben wir so und das hat mir
extrem geholfen aber nicht sagen wir mal
um 1 uhr 30 nach einer 40 minuten rast
phase aufgerufen war 31 in der früh
aufrufen wollte nach vielleicht noch
eine stunde schlaf wie gesagt sofort den
als autor eindhoven und innerhalb von
vier sekunden vom moment oder im auto
drinnen sitzt von vier sekunden schon
180 km h zu fahren ist eine sache wo man
sich denkt okay dass das ist nicht ohne
aber ich bin eingestiegen hab gewusst
eine stunde schlaf reicht jetzt nochmal
und in zwei stunden steige ich hier
wieder aus und kam dann wieder mich ein
bisschen rasten
ich weiß dass eine lange antwort aber
eine eine recht komplizierte antwort
weil eben viel ich beim bundesheer
mitnehmen konnte mit wenig energie oder
sowas viel zu erzeugen zu können und das
hat mir dann die fähigkeit gegeben keine
kurse haben extrem konstant zu sein und
bis zum ende des rennens meistens
schneller wie die anderen werksfahrer
die schon seit mehreren wochen sich auf
dieses rennen vorbereitet in den
schwierigsten umständen in der nacht in
der dunkelheit im regen also dafür bin
ich sehr dankbar eigentlich also wir
froh dass das wirklich dementsprechend
so gut vorbereiten konnten hass auf
seinen helm mitgebracht und einen
rennanzug für die die uns nur hören und
nicht sehen
der helm ist
fasziniert und ich habe vor einer hand
gehabt es irrsinnig leicht aber wirkt
einfach sehr stabil und was man sieht
obwohl und nicht mehr beim bundesheer
bist hast du trotzdem noch ganz von tal
das hoch als abzeichen drauf warum genau
ja ich meine eigengeschäft ich habe
meine saison beginnen sollen während ich
noch beim harry sportzentrum bin also
das design hat sich eigentlich so
ziemlich gut gepasst und ich habe
irgendwie das gefühl gehabt dass das
bundesheer mir sehr viel mitgegeben hat
für die saison und in vielen wegen viele
sportler ist das bundesheer wie ein
sponsor eigentlich sie geben die die
möglichkeiten deinen sport auszuführen
und das ist in meinem fall jetzt nicht
der fall gewesen ich wer trotzdem noch
dtm gefahren aber ich weiß nicht ob ich
die gleichen resultate bekommen hätte
wenn ich nicht die ganzen sachen
mitgenommen hätte die ich dort bekommen
habe deswegen trage ich weiter aus aus
dankbarkeit
das ist natürlich eine tolle sache für
das bundesheer natürlich auch für dich
aber man sieht diese dankbarkeit dieser
zeit ist auch so dass eine
familiengeschichte sehr sehr eng mit mit
der österreichischen geschichte verwoben
ist das hat er mich immer so fasziniert
wenn wir gespräche gehabt habe aber auch
keine unmittelbare familiengeschichte
mit dem bundesheer dein vater war
nämlich als mitglieds offizier pilot
beim bundesheer und da hast
wahrscheinlich viel mitbekommen welche
wichtigkeit auf das bundesheer hat aber
jetzt auch gemeinsam in einem pilatus
pc-7 in zeltweg geflogen wie war diese
erfahrung gemeinsam mit meinem vater
diesen flug zu machen
er heißt balsamico ich war noch nie an
seiner alten station sein alter dort war
halt wie viel zeit verbracht hat und
gelebt hat auch teilweise ich habe immer
viele geschichten gehört weil das
einfach seine große passion war ich
meine er hat es absolut geliebt dort zu
leben und zu arbeiten auch nach seiner
militärzeit dort mit ihm zu sein und
diese geschichten mit zu erleben so wie
er erzählt hat und sein gesicht auf
scheine zu sehen ist wahnsinnig cool
gewesen und prinzipiell aus der erde das
ist einfach wahnsinnig wahnsinnig
aufregend ist dort zu sitzen während
drei oder vier
wir haben es so viel glaube ich piloten
entlang fliegen auf geschwindigkeiten
unglaublich und die flügel sich wirklich
eigentlich berühren während sie kurven
fahren ist für mich eine sache wo ich
für mich sehr viel respekt habe
und auch einfach ein erlebnis das ich
nicht vergessen werde dass ich noch dazu
mit meinem vater teilen durfte das war
eine sache die die die wirklich sehr
wenig menschen mit leben durfte und ich
bin sehr dankbar dass ich das dass ich
einer dieser menschen sein dürfte und
dass jetzt auch schon die
geschwindigkeit angesprochen es gibt
wenige dinge die schneller sind als euro
herein autos flugzeuge sind das auf
jeden fall ist es auch etwas was du dir
vielleicht überlegt das später auch
einmal nicht nur autopilot zu sein
sondern flugzeug pilot ist das eine
überlegung ich habe auf zwei
verschiedenen ebenen mir überlegt ich
habe heute schon immer eigentlich mir
meinen privat flugschein machen
das ist dann nicht der fall geworden
weil ich dann immer eigentlich mein
fokus aufs rennfahren gelegt habe da war
absolut eine zeit nach dem bundesheer wo
ich nicht gewusst habe ob motorsport
sich so weiter bewegt heuer wie wir es
geplant hatten wir haben noch keine
rennen fest gehabt wir haben nix fest
gehabt und das war eine eine eine sehr
unangenehme zeit für mich weil seitdem
ich elf bin weiß ich wann das nächste
rennen ist egal ob es das letzte rennen
in dieser saison war habe ich gewusst
man das erst nächstes jahr ist und ich
habe ein ziel gehabt und während der
bundeswehr habe ich jetzt auch nicht
gewusst waren das passiert aber ich habe
zumindest das bundesheer gehabt wo ich
einen per post auf englisch gesagt wo
ich aushelfen konnte in der nachtschicht
im lagerhaus oder in irgendeiner anderen
kapazität oder mit meinen kameraden
zumindest zusammensein mit denen zur
hackl und zu arbeiten und zu trainieren
und wie das alles zu ende gekommen ist
und ich ausgerückt bin und ich immer
noch nicht gewusst habe man das erste
rennen stattfindet war da ein bisschen
eine zeit wo ich ein bisschen leer war
würde ich sagen und habe mir absolut
überlegt ob ich nicht eine eine
offiziersausbildung beginne und habe
sogar heraus gesucht wo ich das machen
wird das war bei den jägern und das
andere war in zeltweg und sogar
vielleicht pilot zu werden weil das
einfach so ein
wahnsinnig cooler job ist natürlich
würde ich auch sagen dass ich
hoffentlich auch tauglich dafür bin als
als sportler weil das nichts eine super
leichte sache ist zu machen tauglich als
pilot zu sein aber es waren viele
verschiedene faktoren aber es war
absolut einmal in meinem kopf darüber
dann senkt sich dann hat man sie schon
begonnen und alles geändert aber es ist
noch immer im hinterkopf
das heißt die überlegung war da sie wird
vielleicht irgendwann einmal auch dann
werden die g kräfte beim fliegen sollte
ist auf jeden fall aushalten dass jetzt
auch die nachtschicht angesprochen wie
dann die ganze kroner krise ausgebrochen
ist und das bundesheer zur stelle sein
musste und im lager also in den rewe
lagern ausgeholfen hat du hast da eben
der nachtschicht mitgeholfen von 10 uhr
nachts bis 6 uhr in der früh mit der
frage wie 24 stunden rennen das
eigentlich die zeit wo man sich erholt
und von lang vom anstrengenden
trainingstag sich wieder herstellt wie
wahr dieser zeit für dich dass du als
grundwehrdiener im lager fast und in
dieser schwierigen zeit geholfen hast
das war wirklich eine sache wo man auf
man stolz sein konnte weil man seinem
land wirklich teenie kanals als
heeressportler kriegst du sehr viel vom
bundesheer aber ich würde zeigen dass du
nicht wirklich ein soldat bisher
wirklich sich wahnsinnig fürs land viel
einsetzt sondern es geht wirklich darum
dass das bundesheer dafür da ist dir zu
helfen und und das land zu tragen wenn
du dann ein sportler auftritt und das
ist ein super system aber ich würde
sagen dass diese zeit wo wir wirklich
eingesetzt wurden um das land zu
unterstützen war eine sache die mich
überrascht hat dass so etwas nennt sich
eine sache auf die ich nicht frau
bereits hat zwar aber die die
grundausbildung hat genug mit zu geben
dass das ich gewusst habe was man dort
macht aber es kamen mit sehr viel stolz
und freude eigentlich es hört sich
vielleicht komisch an dass man normal
ist dass ich nichts von 10 bis 6
arbeiten will aber mit den kameraden
zusammen
diese nachtschichten durch zu arbeiten
war eine sache die ich ja ich habe zb am
tag irgendwann bei meiner großmutter
angerufen
die mutter von meiner mutter aus
schottland und er ihr vater war ein
recht hoher offizier der britischen
armee und ist in den krieg gezogen und
ich habe ihm erzählt davon wie ich dabei
und sie hat mir immer gesagt die stolze
war dass ich unterstützung weil für sie
es ist eine ältere dame ist der krone
auch ein gegner wie ein krieg und und
das war für siegen werden eine coole
sache das hat mich sehr getäuscht
das heißt da war die oma nicht nur aus
diesem grund aber auch aus diesem grund
stolz auf ferdinand jetzt hast du vorher
auch gesagt dass du immer dieses ziel
hat ist und immer das nächste rennen
geplant hatte und wusste seine
stattfindet wie wird man rennfahrer oder
wie kommt man auf die idee rennfahrer zu
werden
wie komme ich auf die idee oder wie das
bei dir genau wisst ihr gekommen
rennfahrer ja ich habe ihn in salzburg
gelebt einer anfangsphase in meines
lebens und ich habe mich dass das mein
vater hasst es wenn ich das sage aber
dass ich mich nicht wahnsinnig
interessiert für die schule gehasst
trifft mich das nächstes jahr und bin
dann nach wien gezogen in normal- und
mich hat viel mehr interessiert musik
und verschiedene sportarten der
unterricht in der schule war für mich
der minimum einer meiner meiner
aufmerksamkeit gerade genug dass ich
durchgekommen weil das war ein muss
sonst durfte ich meinen ganzen spaß
aufhören und eins davon war dann hat
mich mein vater mitgenommen am
wochenende zu einer strecke wo sie
sonntag früh für alter zwischen sechs
und zehn trainings hatten und wo sie
natürlich nicht erlaubt waren go kart zu
fahren in dem alter bedürftig mit sieben
schon sonntag bevor die kartstrecke
aufgemacht hat trainieren gehen mit
diesen kindern und das hat mich so
gereizt dass ich jeden sonntag mein
vater dazu gezwungen eine bergstrecke zu
bringen und das haben auch gemacht hat
das war super lustig wir sind dann auch
sehr noch car training gefahren wo ich
mit meinem vater geliebt habe und so
weiter dann bin ich mit elf bin ich dann
alt genug geworden dass ich mir
vielleicht was größeres ausgesucht habe
bin dann auf die outdoor kartstrecke
bucher leiter gestoßen durch mehrere
connection singen wie ich habe gewusst
dass das mir sehr gefällt und hab dann
dort zu weihnachten mein eigenes gehalt
bekommen
das war vielleicht ein fehler von meinen
eltern weil wenn heute ein eigenes
burkhardt hast bin ich jeden tag nach
der schule zu meiner mutter gesagt kann
ich bitte geld verspielt haben relation
vielleicht ein fünfziger gegeben wenn
sofort irgendwie zur car jacking
gekommen und habe dort runden getreten
ist der tank ausgelaufen ist dadurch
wieder aufgefüllt und unten gedreht bis
450 euro ausgelaufen sind und ich war
komplett obsessed er hat keine zeit für
schule gehabt und wollte auch noch immer
mehr gitarre spielen und meine bands
unterstützen
also ich war ein relativ hyperaktives
kind aber meine noten manning nicht so
top und immer hat meine mutter mir
gesagt okay entweder du entscheidest
sich merken schule ist nicht sein ding
entweder du wirst rennfahrer oder
rock'n'roll star oder oder musiker und
habe entschieden ok mit elf oder zwölf
da ich las die musik und konzentriere
mich aufs kartfahren dass eine menge
gefallen und ich sage jetzt ich war
nicht ein riesentalent ja es war nicht
so als ob ich gegen wie ein wahnsinnig
schneller kart fahrer und ein
schrecklicher sänger sondern ich war ein
schreckliches leben aber nicht so
schlimm dass ich jetzt sagen würde das
eine das andere
mir hat es einfach mehr gefallen und
habe dann irgendwann normal mit 13 oder
14 begonnen für die österreichische kart
meisterschaft zu kämpfen und habe sich
dann eben noch mal gewonnen und bin dann
zur weltmeisterschaft angetreten waren
zwei jahre hintereinander unter den
ersten zehn barakat weltmeisterschaft
und rassist und dazwischen zeigt das
heißt du hast du das fressen dann auch
schon von klein auf gelernt noch bevor
du deinen führerschein hat das ja das
was mich immer fasziniert dass er als
rennfahrer oder du in dem sinne schon
mehrere zehntausend kilometer
wahrscheinlich infos hast befördert dann
überhaupt offiziell in den
straßenverkehr losgelassen wirst immer
für mich so faszinierend wenn du jetzt
in die zukunft schaut
ich meine der dtm verändert sich derzeit
sehr viel es wird ein neues reglement
geben es wird viele veränderungen geben
wo siehst du dich siehst du dich eher in
richtung verändert der dtm oder hast du
als rennfahrer noch das große ziel
formel 1 formel zeit war es ja auch
schon in der formel 3 aktive welche
richtung zieht es dichter das ist eine
eine nicht zu leichte frage weil ich
keine konkrete antwort habe und versuche
es so offen zu halten wie möglich möchte
schauen was kommt ich möchte weiterhin
so liefern wie es gerade tue weil es
einfach super läuft und ich spaß habe
dabei aber mein ganzes leben lang war
irgendwie die regel
ich muss das lieben was ich tue und
jetzt weil es gut läuft und so und es
angebote gibt
möchte ich nicht irgendwie das ändern
also ich möchte weiterhin die regel
beibehalten ich muss das lieben
ob das am ende des tages dtm wird oder
lähmung oder zurück in die formel 2 oder
wie auch immer oder ins bundesheer
einzutreten einzurücken ist ist es
wahnsinnig offen
ich möchte da nicht irgendwie zu viele
linien festsetzen ich möchte diese regel
einhalten und und vielleicht dieses
podcast wieder halten ein paar monaten
man ist sehr konkret sagen hallo so weil
ich das unterschrieben hat darauf freue
ich mich auf jeden fall schon aber dann
bleiben wir bei deiner regel was liebt
ferdinand habsburg noch viele sachen
vielleicht mal teststrecke also wenn man
wenn man sich vorstellt daran sport ist
es sehr vereinnahmend auch zeitlich auch
energetisch du hast vor die musik
angesprochen dass jahre spielen und sie
hängen hast du dann wahrscheinlich
irgendwann sein lassen oder gibt es
etwas wo du sagst das ist mir so eine
passion das mache ich so irrsinnig gerne
als ausgleich als balance als
regeneration gibt es dinge aus deinem
leben wo du sagst das ist das was ich
neben dem rennsport noch liebe ja ich
meine ich würde sagen mein leben basiert
sich auf 3
das ist meine karriere als rennfahrer
das ist meine familie und der andere ist
mein glaube eigentlich und ich würde
sagen wie wollen sie sich die zeit
verbreitete grund dann auf die zeit des
jahres würde ich sagen familie
inkludiert auch freunde und beziehungen
außerhalb der familie weil ich einfach
es wichtig finde meine energie von
menschen zu bekommen die ich die kleber
und die mich lieben dass das irgendwie
wichtiger als mensch das habe ich
relativ schnell lernen müssen weil
motorsport nicht ohne ist und man mit
viel druck eigentlich schon mit einem
jungen alter umgehen muss und bringt es
sehr viel wenn man jemanden hat er zu
hause ist der mitte ein paar stunden
vielleicht verspielt oder etwas blödes
ja ich in der off-season verbringe ich
dann mehr zeit auch mit dem glauben
wieder weil es doof ist wenn man nicht
immer am sonntag die messe gehen kann
wenn man rennen hat oder um ein bisschen
auf so würde ich mal sagen und mehr zeit
mit der familie zur weihnachtszeit und
so weiter vor allem familie ist weil das
jetzt auch angesprochen hast du auch
weiß ich auch aus unseren gesprächen
sehr sehr wichtig ist natürlich auch in
einer exponierten position wo seine
familie auch sehr viel beachtung findet
wie gehst du damit um auch als kaiser
urenkel immer wieder genannt zu werden
und ins spiel gebracht zu werden ist das
etwas wo du damit umgehen kannst oder
was eigentlich gar nicht möchtest du
möchtest dass man sich endlich voll auf
die ich als person oder auf dich als
rennsportler oder auf das was du sonst
noch mit brings konzentriert wie siehst
du das wenn mich jemand beurteilt
darüber dass sie denken dass sich der
kaiser sein urenkel bin dann finde ich
das nicht ganz fair
prinzipiell beurteilungen bevor du mit
jemandem einmal ein gespräch halten ist
hatte bin ich dagegen aber das ist
wirklich fast nie der fall
ich finde dass wenn jemand mich ist aber
mal kronprinz nennt oder oder kaiser
oder sowas und das mit einem herzen
merke ich jemand dass sie das aus
respekt meiner familiengeschichte
gegenüber machen oder gegenüber meinen
großvater oder meinem urgroßvater und
dafür bin ich wahnsinnig dankbar weil
ich finde es wunderschön wenn ich
menschen kennenlernen
die durch mit ihren respekt durch meine
vorfahren meine vorfahren aufhalten und
dass das finde ich wunderschön und bin
wahnsinnig dankbar dafür den namen
tragen zu dürfen
vor den menschen so viel respekt haben
weil ich habe es nicht gemacht ich hab
nicht gelebt und ich verschließe sich
versöhnlich ich bin nur der der herr ein
geboren wurde und den namen trägt und
versuche es so gut wie möglich
ich weiß nicht ob ich das gut mache wenn
ich sage dass ich nicht in der schule
aufgepasst habe aber ich hoffe dass es
irgendwie machen indem ich mein leben
lebe wie schuhe in dem ich meine passion
nachgehen und offen über meinen glauben
rede oder oder prinzipiell über mein
leben sehr offen bin hoffentlich tut es
das unterschiedlich ich zurückblicke vor
20 jahren denke dass wir trotzdem auf
jeden fall nicht und auch durch seine
sportlichen erfolge
er trickst natürlich unser land mit
stolz nach außen und auch das
hoheitszeichen am helm und rennanzug
herzlichen danke für die spannenden
einblick in deiner karriere und auch in
dein leben lieber ferdinand alles gute
viel gesundheit und pass auf dich auf
und danke auch fürs zuhören fürs dabei
sein beim sport report wir freuen uns
schon auf das nächste mal also unbedingt
wieder dabei
bis dann und servus
[Applaus]
[Musik]